it is it's out of out of every episode
it's the lowest rated one it's called
the under dwellers season one episode
i know it's a great name um
it is it is colloquially in my apartment
known as the episode where everybody in
gotham is just a little high like just
just
today we're going to talk about the best
moments from batman the animated series
and to start us off we are going to ask
nina to tell us
about the episode that we told her to
watch because this is a show
that she didn't watch and that's fine
because it was on before she was born
when was it on
like the early maybe you were like an
infant when this show was on when did it
when did it start you have to know this
93 i was born in 1990 i'm not okay you
know no you have a lucky sense of time
because you've been alive for centuries
i've been alive
the gen foreign of the of this channel
because i'm not
but to be fair to be perfectly fair this
is a show you haven't seen and that's
okay because it was well before your
time it's a show i feel like like when i
sat down to watch this episode i it was
a show that i felt like was like a
cultural osmosis thing because i have
just seen like clips of it used in many
other kind of
you know context and properties for so
long like the the way batman's drawn in
batman the animated series is like super
iconic and i feel like that's the way
i've always seen like a drawn a cartoon
batman look does that make sense like
yeah it's always been like that
depiction that's what it is right right
yeah like i'm sure there have been other
batman you know shows and stuff but it's
like that's the one i understand it's
for me for me
mine is the super friend style batman
because when i was a kid oh yeah batman
and robin would team up with like scooby
doo
yeah he would just be goofy and dumb and
like there was adam west batman so that
was batman for me so then when this [ __ ]
came on when i was in like elementary
school i was like oh my god and it just
like
blew the brain out of the back of my
head it was just let you in an
elementary school in your 50s
yes
i'm incredibly stupid
[Laughter]
my spirit animal booboo the fool anyway
yeah see we got this list we have this
list on looper.com and one of the first
ones on here is uh heart the episode
heart of ice particularly the snow globe
which you'll see at the end of the
episode so that was the one
the one where it turns out that same
elsewhere was all
yeah it was all happening in batman the
animated series no so uh
brian told me to watch this episode i'm
just gonna because i've already had my
dirty laundry hung out to dry that's
what happened it's fine
and i'm so excited for the comments on
this one yikes it's fine
so i did watch our device really good
episode like yeah and
yeah i mean mr freezes as you both told
me a pretty lame villain all things
considered especially in other
depictions but this was a like a very
perfectly contained 22-minute you know
saga of a guy it was also like very
depressing like you know his he loses
his wife he just wants he wants to make
ferris doyle right who's voiced by mark
hamill the evil corrupt ceo of
goth corp you know he wants to make him
suffer so mark hamill is like well known
as being the voice of the joker on the
show right before he got that gig
regularly he did this role because of
the way that they recorded this all oh
dip okay because yeah yeah he had this
role first and then tim curry was
supposed to be the joker i think this is
how it went and then either tim curry
had to drop out or they just decided it
wasn't a good fit either way
mark hamill got the role i think after
this and so yeah right but yes well i
know chronologically this this series
comes later but i like to call that like
law and order syndrome or like uh early
in like law or special victims you know
an actress played a woman accused of
assaulting like a male dancer and then
two seasons later she was the district
attorney and i was like
she really she really yeah what a glow
on look at this woman yeah yeah
so yeah the system works you guys really
does she was she was reformed so yeah so
i watched um
heart advice really solid episode so
batman gets a cold from a freeze gun
which i'm not you know like from an
epidemiology standpoint i don't know if
that really attracts but
it works um it works it's okay
it lowered his immune system and yeah he
caught a cold that's why they call it a
couple okay
science
[Music]
so but the best part of the episode by
far is that the chicken soup that alfred
gives to batman bruce wayne is what ends
up defeating mr freeze and i was like oh
it's like chicken soup for the cold soul
or something like that
set up
yeah set up and pay off but it was just
like such a such a doofy little piece of
setup and payoff and i just i loved it
it was extremely fun um yeah yeah nice
little bite-sized episode i mean
animation's always shorter right even if
a full-length animated movie is never
more than like 90 minutes because it
just takes so long like logistically
yeah right yeah it's a very labor
intensive process but yeah super fun
episode thanks for telling me to watch
it i want to go back and watch them
it was yeah one of the things that we we
talked about a little bit in our chat
before we hopped on here was the fact
that and you alluded to this just a
minute ago that um prior to this mr
freeze was just a very lame villain this
backstory this character wasn't really
in place and so when they were making
this episode they wrote a tragic villain
and this really like he's really cold
pun intended and very like
emotionally cut off because of the
accident that he's right doesn't he say
like he really can't feel anything
anymore because
because he's he has to live in the
subzero suit because he yeah he fell
into his own cold research yeah science
he's just very sad all the time yeah
it's beautiful it's a beautiful little
metaphor and it's just kind of this
weirdly
like it's a mini movie it's a 22 minute
mini movie yeah it's perfect it's got a
great three-act structure you've got
your main antagonist your secondary
antagonist
uh
the set up to pay off with the chicken
soup it's just it's just perfect really
good voice acting
really solid voice acting across the
board
amazing voice acting and just that sad
moment of dr freeze in his jail cell
like apologizing to his late wife for
not getting the revenge that he promised
and batman even feels bad about it and
you're like yo
everything in this show is generally a
gigantic bummer and that's why it's so
it's really cool because at the time
like this this was groundbreaking at the
time because they were trying to put
they were trying to do this noir kind of
more adult look at this
at batman but do it for a kid's show and
and they had to fight standards and
practices that's the tone that they were
going for then they nailed it they had
to like they had to like argue to let
batman punch people they had to argue to
let
bad guys have guns
that
wouldn't get shot by you know like right
just all these things that we take for
granted as stuff that you can kind of
get away with in most
you know things most things in media
like at that time it was just like you
can't do that this is a kid show this is
for children right and so you know the
fact that it can end tragically and
there's we're going to talk more about
this stuff in a few minutes but yeah
just this is one of my favorites so i'm
really i'm excited you finally saw it
and i'm excited that you're definitely
going to watch more we're going to have
more conversations about it yeah i mean
you're going to message me every day and
ask if i have so i you know i already
wanted to but now i'm gonna get bullied
about it so extra incentive for me
that's what i do i bully people at work
to watch cartoons i like the way that
the tables have turned on our lives
collectively that we're now the ones
bullying people into watching batman
instead of
yes that's not what it was like when i
was a kid tom
tom what about you what is what is your
pick from this list
i'm glad you asked brian uh so i i i i
don't know i feel like this the show has
such a such a huge following and and
such a passionate following that kind of
all of the the best episodes have kind
of been have been talked about you know
uh
there were only what there were four
seasons there were 109 episodes
something like that something it was i
think there were three seasons on fox
and then it moved to wb and they changed
the animation style to modernize it and
that was the fourth season so that's why
if you look at hbo max the first couple
of seasons look very classic very kind
of like retro styling and then the final
season is very much in the vein of like
the justice league unlimited cartoon the
superman animated series cartoon like
it's a style by then
everything kind of like got
got really streamlined into this one
style but anyway i interrupted you go
ahead no not at all we're talking about
a thing we're excited about and that
thing's bad man i what i decided that i
wanted to do is i put a little bit of
sauce on the on the prompt
i put some sauce on it brian good
and what i decided to do was to try and
find in instead of the best episode i i
decided i wanted to find redemption for
the worst one i think i know what the
worst one is i would what what do you
think it is because i went to imdb i
looked it up i i i found which one i
have two choices
okay i have two choices for what this is
one is tiger tiger oh interesting okay
was that it that's not it where they
turn catwoman into a catwoman and it
sucks
i mean i don't that was a lot of the
only reason why that would suck
that one was was one of them i think the
one where i think his name was like
nostromos or something where batman
takes on a grifter who's like all about
astrology that was another one that was
kind of that's great that one no it's
not that one okay is it the one with is
it i've got batman in my basement is it
that one no but i thought about that one
is it the one where they go down into
the sewers with the sewer king guy okay
that is the one i knew it was one of
those one of those ones
like mole people yeah he like abducts a
bunch of kids tom tell tell us about
this
episode this i would love to so it's it
it is it's out of out of every episode
it's the lowest rated one it's called
the underdwellers season one episode
i know it's a great name um
it is it is colloquially in my apartment
known as the episode where everybody in
gotham is just a little high
like just just
not like all the way high not like lying
on the couch high but like definitely
kind of spacey
uh
like a few too many cbd gummies didn't
actively go further than that yeah yeah
yeah like there wasn't supposed to be
phd in this but like i feel
uh
so the episode starts out with this a
lady gets her purse stolen by somebody
small and she says a leprechaun did it
and then batman runs after the small
person the alleged leprechaun it loses
them and then goes back
to the bat cave and says
i think a leprechaun stole a purse and
alfred at this point is listening to
classical music but he's like bopping
out to it like he's he's having a groovy
time doing this and then alfred says it
probably wasn't a leprechaun though
right and batman says maybe i need a
rest and then alfred says maybe you need
a rest and then batman says i think it
was a leprechaun and uh
that's not how i remember this this is
i'm i'm giving you a condensed version
uh paraphrasing okay
it turns out the leprechaun thing by the
way just a real zebra of a diagnosis if
you're asking me like they find a small
guy and you say you know what i probably
it turns out of course it's actually a
kid uh the kid is part of a dickensian
orphan sewer gang being run by a real
hat on the hat original villain named
the sewer king who was played by an
actor named michael pataki who was a
character actor who actually played a
goon in the original
like 1966 batman tv show with adam west
he was one of king tut's goons also a
klingon in the trouble with triples
episode of star trek nina have you
watched star trek yet
no what's the actor's name
michael palicky he's the he's the one in
the
uh arapatiki excuse me he is the one in
the bar who says that the enterprise
should be hauled away as garbage okay
but it's not one of the three klingons
who came back in deep space nine to team
up with dax no but he did uh show up
again in uh next generation as a
different character it doesn't matter
i'm getting off topic pointing out sorry
guys
on this show so that's really
unacceptable it's never happened before
uh
this is unprecedented he's got a writing
cloak he's got glasses with one lens
blacked out and like a walking stick and
he doesn't let the children speak he
just sends them out to steal him very
studio ghibli looking food like this
delicious cartoon food
and he owns like at minimum eight
alligators
it's it's not clear how many alligators
he has in total i i i thought i clocked
eight of them they've all got alligator
collars it's unclear where he's getting
those i think the dickensian orphans are
probably producing them in a sweatshop
somewhere below the surface you know oh
okay god i thought i thought you meant
as like a biological thing it was like
okay you know the colors
the real winning detail of the episode
for me is that uh we find out two things
that the batmobile can do
uh that i was not aware of up until this
point the first one is that it can
transform into a garbage dumpster nice
as a form of disguise which is what it
is and then the second one is that it
has like a built-in
tiny television screen
that appears to be the
batman finds one of the kids and he
brings him back to wayne manor and uh
on the drive over i guess to to to stop
the kid from from realizing where he's
going he pops out this little television
screen in the the dashboard of the car
and it plays a spirally thing and then
it puts the kid to sleep so batman has
like a
kid's sleep
machine well didn't we actually see that
in batman begins didn't didn't he have
something like that in the batmobile to
put rachel to sleep when they were going
to the uh to the bat the bat cave or was
she or was she suffering no she was just
she was drugged up on the uh
the fear gas and she was about to die
the idea of a uh a forced sleep machine
in the batmobile yeah
women and children usually want kids
yep ladies super weird no bad bad idea
don't do that so you are going to redeem
this episode right tom you haven't done
a great job yeah
yeah
yeah it turned out there was nothing
it's just really bad
okay
yeah no it's a tragedy i like this one
of the alligators like that's why it's
on this list that is one of the the
lesser episodes uh other ones on this
list that we'll briefly mention
this is this is this is about moments
from batman the animated series so nina
you talked about the chicken soup
tom you talked about the batmobile as
dumpster as your favorite moment i did
love that yeah that's awesome
so on this list we've got the snow globe
from the very end of heart of ice which
is a pretty classic iconic moment we've
got batman's identity revealed in the
strange secret of bruce wayne with a
very old batman villain that they
adapted for the animated series hugo
strange who shows up in the batman
arkham city video game he's a very pulpy
villain he's got like a thick german
accent and like dark glasses and he's
like
captures a batman or whatever he says
that's a direct quote yes thank you uh
scenes from uh
bruce wayne battling batman in the
episode per chance to dream so in that
one mad hatter he captures batman sticks
device on his head
next thing batman knows he wakes up he's
bruce wayne he's not batman anymore and
so he's going through this life he's not
batman but batman's out there doing
stuff but he gets to be bruce wayne with
living parents and eventually he freaks
out because he can't deal with the fact
that
you know he gets the sense that this
isn't real and confronts batman
of of this reality and he figures out
that he's he thinks he's in a dream and
so bruce wayne is like all right i'm
gonna jump off this high tower now and
batman's like if you do that you'll die
and he's like i think i'll wake up but
either way it's better than living a lie
and he's stone cold tries to just he
just jumps he jumps to his death
basically and then he wakes up and he
beats the bad guy and it's like again
like
it's all a gigantic bummer but it's all
very like thematically
it's cool stuff it's it's it's cool
stuff for it's cool stuff for kids to
figure out that's very what was that
what was that uh alan moore superman
story the gift
what is it gift for the man the man who
has everything that's what it's called
it's very that um
yeah there's another one on here the
batman unite where he teams up with the
great ghost voiced by adam west great
there's a lot of good ones on here i
went off menu to pick two of my own
favorites because again like i was like
i want to talk about this show but i
don't want to pick something from this
list just because i know that there's
stuff that i like that i want to bring
up and one of them was an episode called
the joker's favor
um
and it starts off with this guy named
charlie just driving his car and he's
all like mad and he's like
everything stinks my life is terrible
and finally he gets cut off by someone
driving a station wagon and he's like
that's it i'm gonna give this guy a
piece of my mind he's like at the end of
his rope and he starts he drives after
this guy who cut him off he like bumps
his car with his car which is like in a
cartoon is fine but in reality that's
like no you have to call you have to
call a cop you have to get the insurance
involved but anyway let's pretend that
that could happen that you could play
bumper cars with your car
anyway he starts cursing at the driver
and then he finds out that the guy
driving it is the joker
and he freaks
he freaks out because he's like i just
started screaming at the joker and this
great this great scene uh ensues where
he's like running away from the joker
trying to get away and the joker's
following him and
um it's like it's this
first of all it's amazing whenever like
i know you guys don't drive but when i
when i when i drive and i do something
goofy
yeah
another driving the bus that we neither
of us can drive
you're both riding because you don't
drive
but whenever i drive and i do something
dumb
right i'm like oh this guy's gonna see i
don't wanna sit next to him at a light
he's going to look at me because i just
like cut him off and it was
it's like that but like a homicidal
maniac is coming right like like you
look over and it's tony soprano but
right and you're like
or tony soprano and joker makeup
even scarier
no just like someone that you know is
like trouble yeah that's gonna
seriously come after you i don't know if
james gandolfini and clown makeup is
chocolate and peanut butter quite the
way that you think it is yeah
it's this amazing moment because it's
it's one of the first times in the in
the series that you see
someone reacting to the joker who's not
batman it's i was gonna say it seems
like it's outside the context of batman
for like one second which is cool well
for most of the show batman is barely in
this episode he shows up in the last six
minutes to save the day and it's
basically about this guy
he like like after just kissing the
joker by accident yeah he pisses off the
joker the joker takes his id he's like
you owe me a favor bye
and then it cuts to two years later and
this dude has moved to ohio and changed
his name he gets a phone call from the
joker he's like
i got that favor and he's like you got
the wrong number he's like no i got the
right number here's your whole family
and again kids cartoon amazing stuff it
just so happens also this is a really
good episode for a lot of reasons but i
love that this episode teaches kids like
witness protection does not work they
will always find you
don't bother
don't bother you anyway bad guys will
always find you
you can't hide
but this also happens
the episode that features the very first
the first appearance of harley quinn
oh
first appearance ever and she's just on
our list this is a good one
well i mean that's the thing she it's
there's so much to choose from with this
yeah but um she's just there in the
joker's hideout when he's like
complaining about his bit you know he's
got this big scheme where he's going to
blow up
like the police force because they're
doing a big dinner for for commissioner
gordon and so harley quinn is just there
just like
yeah the commissioner sucks or whatever
she says it's just like right she's this
amazing character who's fully formed
from day one
right in my opinion a lot of the
backstory they've kind of given her
diminishes kind of her strength of just
like this
this great sassy side character who's
just
this amazing
extra extra punch to to the joker and i
like that that harley has gotten a lot
more
uh starring roles that we've learned
more about her generally i feel like the
backstory that she was a a psychiatrist
who fell in love with the joker doesn't
and also like an olympic level gymnast
these two these two things don't quite
go together for me but i'm just i'm
picking knits
harley's great she's a great character
it's great that she's introduced in this
episode this is a classic episode the
other one i watched really briefly
because i've been talking for a while is
um
it's called read my lips and i've
mentioned before my love of the
ventriloquist and scar brian
okay so but here's the thing i've got my
moment picked out so for the last one
the moment was when the joker runs this
guy down and he's like hiding from the
joker and you get to see someone really
afraid of the joker
for this one there's the reveal that
that the big bad guy is a is a puppet
and this is the face that they show
bruce wayne make bratman making in the
episode i've shared it in our chat
like that's the big reveal
[Laughter]
he looks just like he's straight up just
like what the
is going on just he cannot even
deal
with what he's seeing
and i just love it i love them i just
started laughing because i was like yeah
if i was a crime fighter and i saw that
seriously mob boss who's committing
these amazing heists all over gotham was
literally a puppet i might make that
face too
it seems appropriate
yeah so anyway
outstanding show thanks for watching
please hit like and subscribe
[Music]